أوفر قاصيف هو عضو في الكنيست
للقائمة المشتركة
وهو في إعادة تأهيل لإسرائيل عبر سكايب أه
فقط ليعطي
أه نشكرك على انضمامك إلينا لمنح
مشاهدينا بعض
المسابقة ويصححني إذا كنت مخطئًا فأنت
العضو اليهودي الوحيد في
تحالف الأحزاب السياسية العربية
هذا صحيح ، نعم ،
هذا رائع ،
حسنًا ، ما رأيك في ما
يجري الآن مع حملة نتنياهو
لمواصلة
استهداف أهداف داخل غزة الآن
ماذا
كيف تفعل  أنت ترد عليها وماذا
تأمل أن يحدث في
الأيام والأسابيع القادمة أولا وقبل كل شيء
يجب أن يعلم الجميع أن نتنياهو
نفسه وطبعا البلطجية من
حوله البلطجية الذين يطلق عليهم
حكومة إسرائيل هم المسؤولون
عن الحريق الذي أشعل النار.
وبدأت في ذلك عن قصد ، وليس من
قبيل المصادفة
أن النار اندلعت في نفس اليوم إلى
حد ما أن
التفويض بتشكيل الحكومة انتقل من
نتنياهو
إلى سجن نتنياهو بإطلاق النار
مرة واحدة.  لم يستطع
تشكيل حكومة ،
لذا فهو مسؤول عن إراقة الدماء
، فهو مسؤول عن
أي قطرة دم تراق من
اليهود والفلسطينيين ، لذا
يجب إلقاء اللوم عليه وعلى حكومته
ومن أجل ذلك.  لإنهاء نعم ، آسف ،
آسف ، لم أقصد مقاطعتك ،
لكنك تقول في الأساس إنه
ساخر للغاية ،
فأنت تقول إنه فعل كل هذا
لأسباب سياسية وأن هذا
لا علاقة له بأمن إسرائيل
، وبالتالي  أكثر من 200 قتيل في
غزة
و 10 قتلى إسرائيليين أه حقًا
أه
لقد حدث هذا بسبب أفعاله ،
لقد لخصت وجهة نظري
تمامًا وأود أن أقول أكثر من
ساخر وسأكون صريحًا جدًا وجديدًا
حاد
جدا وآمل أن الناس الذين
يشاهدوننا سيفهمون ذلك
وسوف يستوعبون ما قلته قبل
عام في الفصل أن نتنياهو
مختل عقليا فرموني وأقول ذلك مرة أخرى  إنه
مريض نفسيًا سريريًا لا يهتم
قليلاً بحياة ورفاهية
زملائه ، ولا يهتم إلا
بنفسه ، فهو يريد البقاء في السلطة من
أجل البقاء خارج
السجن وهذا هو السبب الوحيد
الذي جعلنا  كنت أعاني في الأسبوع
الماضي
أو أو ثمانية أيام ، وخاصة
بالطبع أهل غزة ، قلبي يذهب
لأهل غزة وكذلك
لأهل إسرائيل
يعانون لأن هذا السيكوباتي لا يزال
في السلطة وأتمنى أن تفوزوا "  سيكون في
السلطة قريبا جدا